Exam is at nine 15 only, right?
Yeah. Yes, yes, yes. Another 15 minutes to wait. Okay.
Yeah. Yeah. I think they also have,
uh, set up for tomorrow.
Also, there's an exam. People
who couldn't attend today can do it tomorrow.
Oh, okay. Okay. Tomorrow,
four o'clock they have set the door.
Uh, tomorrow it's seven to 8:00 PM Seven to eight. Okay.
And then the deep learning assignment date has changed.
You're saying it'll be pushed by? Yeah.
Uh, sir, actually I instructed, uh, uh, the TA to change it
to, uh, next week, 22nd.
Okay. Okay. I, you can,
Sir. Still we
have time. Okay.
Okay. Okay, good. No, no.
After people work according
to the timelines on the assignment.
Right. That's why if it
No, if we can change now, only again,
someone will tell sir, no, we can't, we don't want 25 again,
you'll change like that.
They will tell, sir,
Earlier it was 18th, right?
Uh, now, presently, it's 18th, sir,
but deadline, I'm giving on 25th. That is on Sunday.
Okay. Okay. Thank you. 18th to 25th. Okay. Okay.
But, uh, this date is not yet changed. I think. Right. 20.
They'll change. Just not, they'll change.
Same thing. On that day, only I have changed,
but anyone again, uh, someone will come
and they tell us, sir, we can't submit on 25th.
That's why I waited to change.
Oh, okay. No problem.
Madam, Madam, at end of this, uh, this, uh, this thing,
you, you retell that, uh, 25th is the last date
for submitting because, uh, later, so many questions
and all those kind of stuff will
come to avoid the confusion. But you tell 25th
And already I have changed the date. 20
Madam. I agree. Agree, agree.
But still, there are people who,
who don't see the LMS better to tell verbally also in this,
after the, the examination is over.
Sarah, If we change anything in the lms,
you'll get the notification, right,
Madam, there are, uh, certain people still,
they have not, they're not checking that one.
That is the reason. This is my humble request.
Let, it's up to you.
No, no, sir. Uh, it's good thing.
Uh, but what I'm saying means, uh,
if you change anything means it'll revert to your,
uh, LMS also.
And you will get the notification also, right?
Based on our changes,
Ma'am, we don't get, we don't get notification
notification, but we can see it in our dashboard to log,
we have to log in and see the, in the Chrome browser itself.
We don't contain notification in, uh, phone or something.
We'll get the notification only
regarding the class rescheduling things.
Not, not that things that team mail. Okay?
Okay. Okay. We have to tell that LMS team, we have to get
that notification.
What we are giving the any changes means it'll update, uh,
to you immediately.
Yes. Yes. Sure, sure. That, that will actually help.
There will be no confusion,
Okay? Okay. Sure, sure.
Uh, you have exam at nine 15.
You have to turn on your camera,
Madam, the same. It's
there on the LMS for tomorrow as well, right?
Tomorrow night.
Uh, 7 2 8 7 2 8. But
Huh? Who can't write
on today? No. For who is working?
Yeah, I'll prefer, so I'll log off.
I'll give it on tomorrow night, madam.
Okay? Yeah. No, no, no, no, no, no. That is not fine. Why?
That's why told sir. We'll not change.
We will conduct only one time.
Ah, But, uh, what's the reason
for, uh, writing tomorrow?
Writing tomorrow is today I have, I have to go somewhere.
I just joined in from my car, so that is better.
No, I can join properly.
Okay. Okay, fine. Thank you,
madam. I'll leave now. Yeah.
Okay.
Ma'am, are we expecting class after this exam
or we good to leave?
Sir? Can you come again?
Uh, af after the completion of the exam,
are we expected with any class? No, sir. No,
Sir. You
can exit. You can leave. Sir,
The link is available in the LMS now,
or it's not yet posted.
Lemme check the lms.
You can see it'll open at nine 15, sir. Uh, nine
50.
All the best for your exams. Please turn on your camera.
Otherwise we will not going to evaluate.
I still don't see the link there.
Refresh.
No, I still don't see that.
I just got access to the quiz
and I have started my attempt.
Okay. Refresh your browser.
Yeah, I'm doing that continuously
There. Otherwise you
can rejoin.
The link is down below. Actually not on the problem.
Oh, in the quiz sections. Okay.
I
Can you please switch on your cameras?
Switch on the camera?
Yes. You can leave if you have done with your exams.
Excuse me, ma'am. I have a doctor.
A question is sir, available?
Hello? Which question?
Because it'll, uh, change for everyone. No,
Yeah, it's a short question.
So it says a conation layer has 64 filters,
a kernel with three by three size and input channels, 28.
So do we have to consider bias over here
or should we not consider it?
Can you please confirm it?
Uh, wait one second.
I will tell you by seeing that question.
Uh, can you just tell me the questions question, which was
where you have the doubt.
Uh, so, so the question I, I'll repeat the question.
So it says a convolution layer mm-hmm. Has 64 filters.
Hmm. Uh, and kernel size is three.
Cross three input channels is 1 28.
So it's asking us to find out, uh, the number of, uh,
uh, parameters there.
So I'm just trying to understand if we have
to add the bias or not.
Uh, Because we get different answers if we add,
if we don't add, we get different answers.
Right. I guess we need to add the bias.
Yeah, I believe we need to add,
We need to, right? We need to
Add the bias. We add
to bias. I think we have, we have
to add the bias and we have to
Evaluate that.
Got it. Okay. Thank you.
That is the standard thing, I guess,
where adding the Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly.
But I just got it out since it is not mentioned.
Thank you,
Maam. I just submitted
my attempt, so I'm just uh, plugging off.
Yes. Who have submitted leave. Thank you ma'am.
Yeah, thank you. Thank you.
Uh, hello. I'm done with my exam,
but I have a question with respect to assignment.
So just wanted to know, is it okay to ask that doubt here
or should I just ask it in a different session?
Can you mail, can you, uh, mail me?
Okay. Okay. Done. You mail me.
I'll uh, uh, revert you back. Okay.
Uh, okay. So may I know your email ID please?
I'll uh, put in the chat box. You can check. Okay.
Yep. Thank you. Thank you So much. Okay. Okay.
Uh, hi ma'am. One quick question. Uh, I have a doubt.
In one of the questions it says the conation layer has 64
filters, kernel 3.3 input channels 1 28.
But what is the expectation?
Um, is it finding number of parameters?
It does not ask what is the expect
but giving an given the choices.
So what we need to find out, it's number
of parameters, I guess.
Okay. You should find the number of parameters, number
Of, number of parameters you have to check. Okay.
And we should also include the bias.
That's one more thing. Okay, fine. Thank you. Thanks.
Thanks for,
Yeah, I am done with the exam.
I'm dropping off.
Okay, I'm dropping off. Okay. Yeah. Thank you.
Hi vi. I have one more question.
So there's this question called, uh, it starts with this,
um, with weight, DK is equal to one E minus four
and the optimizer and it has given the weight
and the uh, other thing.
And it is asking for the L two
penalty contribution to the loss.
So here also we have two types of formulas.
One is the normal theory formula
and one is the PyTorch based method.
So which one do we have to follow?
Are you there?
Uh, yes. Yes. Uh,
but what you, uh, said in the lab,
uh, in the question
What we Have to find,
So in the question we, we were given weight,
decay and weight.
So we were asked to find the L two penant
contribution to the loss.
So here also we have two formulas.
One is according to the coding py do coding
and the one is the theoretical one.
So we get two different answers for this.
So which one do we have Follow,
But you have to find the theoretical, uh, formula
Theoretical one.
Uh, because we are not asking here mentioned here S right?
Yeah. I mean sometimes, uh, while differentiation we take,
uh, I'm not sure if I have to say it here, we ha we take it
as by two because we cancel them out.
So now I'm not sure if we have to consider that or not
because sir, also sometimes consider it,
sometimes he doesn't consider it.
We have to consider by two Based on the question
We have to consider by two consider.
Yeah, consider We have to consider it.
We have to consider that.
Okay. We have to consider by two and we have to do it.
Okay. Got it. Uh, Rajs, thank you.
And also, uh, for the other question,
there's a similar question.
And for that formula is given, so in that
by two is not considered,
so I'm still in the,
We have not given you don't consider for that question.
Yeah. If you consider by two then
answer. We are not getting, that's why
We're not getting, that's why we don't
have to consider that.
No, no. We still have an answer there.
Fine. No issues. Thank you.
I think time of right
from nine 15 to 10 15, right? Who is,
No, it's only ten three ma'am.
It's not 10 15. Okay.
Okay. Okay. And I think
what you told in the last question also, if
that is L two regulation formula, if you construc by two,
then we are not getting that answer at all.
So there we don't construc by two. No,
I told that only in the first question.
What she been asked no for there you have
to consider in the second question.
You don't consider that.
Yes. Yes. Okay.
Ma'am, my exam is over. I'm dropping.
So, um, we don't have any class after this, right?
Yes, we don't have class. You can leave now
When we'll receive the result for this one.
Um, will it by evening,
Uh, uh, first of all, quiz also you didn't receive right.
Quiz or, uh,
quiz also result you didn't get, right?
Correct. First, Uh,
if possible I'll uh, display the result tomorrow
or Monday or Tuesday, both.
Okay. But quiz we have
to eliminate three questions, right? As we discussed
With, no, I'll convert that into 10 marks.
Okay. Then I'll give the final answer. Okay? Perfect.
Perfect. 'cause I have to remove that, which all questions.
You have gracing marks?
No, I will remove those questions
and I will give, give the overall 10 marks.
I will give the, how much you have got.
Perfect. Uh, you will get Monday or Tuesday. Okay?
Okay. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you ma'am.
Noted. Thank you. But I mean, uh,
one more question, one or two questions.
The, the multiple, uh, choices are different, ma'am,
can you have a look on that also?
Two questions I think if I'm not wrong.
Uh, sir, can you,
if everyone finish means can you show me the screen, uh,
display or otherwise you can put in the chat box.
I will look going into those questions.
Okay, ma, because I have not set it those questions.
The, another I have set it the ions. Okay. That's why. Yeah.
Okay.
Those questions put in the chat box. I will, uh, check it.
Last one.
Dropping off Uhhuh. Thank you.
You're completed, right? Yeah. Thank you maam.
Just yes, yes, fine. Thank you. Okay. Thank you.
Thank you.